all right so I'm looking at question
seven a particle moving in simple
harmonic motion has this differential
equation X double dot is minus 9x okay
now part one is it's just a standard
result I show that x equals a sine 3t
plus a bar is a solution but this
function is a switch in this
differential equation so you just take
both sides you differentiate it twice to
get the left-hand side and just multiply
it by minus things you get the right
hand side and it works okay so so far so
good
part twos where it gets fun now it says
initially the particles acceleration is
and then it gives you a speed so that's
partly unfortunately maybe want to
correct on your sheet the particles
acceleration is 18 meters per second the
per second so it should be to the power
of minus 2 okay so when time equals zero
right you've got X double dot be equal
to 18 also you get this other condition
when T is 5 PI on 18 which is an awkward
number the velocity is 12 so that the
amplitude of the motion is 4 meters okay
so what I'm required to get is this
result okay because I do have that a
actually specify for me all right so how
do I get this to work part of the reason
why it's confusing is because you've got
all of these equations and they're not
all in the same variable right so that's
why I like some things in terms of time
some things in terms of displacement
what do you do okay so we're I'm going
to begin is with this initial condition
T equals 0 acceleration is 18 okay now
if I know the acceleration because of
this equation I should also know my
position right so if my acceleration is
18 right that means that 18 is equal to
minus 9x right at initial conditions
yeah
so that implies this is where I begin X
is equal to minus
I'm happy with that so far okay now what
do I do it is well I'm going to bring it
back to this equation that I proved in
part one right because that leaks time
nearly time zero and displacement okay
because I'm trying to get an A that's
what I'm trying to work out okay so I'm
going to say when T equals zero
after this x equals -2 so I'm going to
bring that to my displacement equation
so minus 2 equals a sine now times 0 so
3 times T is 0 plus alpha it's just
alcohol okay now I'm going to get
another equation in a second that'll
allow me to solve for this right so in
order to get an A I want to say sine
alpha is equal to minus 2 on a no-no
right now other than this this parts a
bit tricky but as you'll see later you
you start to anticipate this kind of
thing I'm going to need cos alpha as
well because it's going to come into my
expansion okay so I'm going to say it
cos alpha
use your Pythagorean identity right it's
going to be plus or minus the square
root of 1 minus sine squared 1 minus
sine squared isn't a square root okay so
that's going to be 1 plus 4 over square
you're happy with that okay just take
that in your mind for later now the next
piece of information they give they've
given us right I've sort of exhausted
this line so now I've got to go to
velocity ok I don't have a velocity
equation so let's make one okay I've got
displacement so I can get velocity from
that velocity is equal to just
differentiate chain rule 3 comes out the
front sign turns into cosine
and now we have a velocity equation in
terms of time right so that's what I'm
going to bring this into so if I
substitute that in what am I going to
get I'll have 12 over this side I've got
three a now don't forget that a is what
I'm after
okay three a cos 3t there's T so x 35.6
plus alpha okay so I'm going to do with
that well if I want to bring this into
play which is my other piece of
information then I'm going to need to
use the expansion right so I'm going to
have Y suppose I can divide by three so
it gives me four equals a alright think
back
what's your expansion for cos a plus B
this is close collars minus sign sign
right
sorry my bracket so cars five PI on six
and cos alpha right now you can see why
I brought this result in minus sign the
same same okay so far so good now what's
going on here this a I'm going to leave
that at the front we'll get rid of the
second cause five and six
how do your exact values hi part six it
goes down so it's negative it's going to
be minus fifty onto you're like yeah
that's exactly what I was going to say
cos alpha and I know what cos alpha is
now I'm going to take the positive value
okay I'm going to take it as if alpha is
acute so our first quadrant because when
you're thinking about shift which is on
where this equation is coming from right
why would you shift any further than
that right so I can actually sort of
assume it's positive so that's going to
give me this one plus four on a squared
but which looks awful have some faith
okay um yeah yeah so I've got sign five
pound six which is okay so same to sign
pilot six so it's just a half sine alpha
that's sine alpha minus two on
okay okay now have a look at this this
all looks terrible but this a at the
front is the key okay so where this a
comes underneath the square root it's
going to become a square yes so this is
going to be minus root three five two
this is going to become a square plus
four
okay you have a look at this guy
you're like this is really a on two and
two on a and there's a double negative
so it's just one yeah that's really for
right so now when I take it over three
minus root three on sorry that's meant
to be a free once here and a squared
plus four now you can almost see it
didn't matter whether I took the
negative value for cause or not because
it is second I'm going to square out
okay bring this over so let's see here
that's going to be six on root 3 that's
such a true root 3 isn't it yes a
squared plus 4 you square it out that
gives you 12 wait a second something
missing that should be a minus what not
miss oh that that's that's wrong sorry
guys no one picked it up heard it like
five times
come on guys he's like mr. nicely oh ok
well thanks I was kind of is good thanks
team sorry ok there we go okay there we
are 4 comes over now of course it
doesn't matter whether a is plus or
minus because I'm like I'm interested in
this amplitude which is a scaler right
so the amplitude is four okay now very
simple result right in terms of the
number but you see how many twists and
turns you have to go through the hardest
part was what they were set up right it
was just a normal set up okay um
they gave us all these different
equations in terms of different things
that's why you've got to be very careful
as you go through okay it doesn't make
sense